but first let's take a closer look at
how the
radical left is now tainting america's
most important
and most revered institutions let's
start
with the fbi now for years this program
has detailed high ranking members of the
fbi
abused the fisa court system i told you
many times
premeditated fraud on the fisa court to
spy on a presidential candidate
and on a president and a transition team
and just last week a newly declassified
report
from a fisa court judge corroborated
everything that we have been telling you
all along
they found widespread violations in the
warrant process
now congressman jim jordan andy biggs
they are demanding
rightly so answers and specifically
what is the bureau doing to prevent the
warrantless surveillance
of american citizens and protecting our
civil liberties
by the way fbi director ray where are
you
do you even care to comment are you
doing anything
at all to prevent the further abuse of
power
and corruption because the 99 of good
agents
they deserve for you to clean it up we
are now
years now we've been telling you about
comey and company
you know carter page using the hillary
clinton bought and paid for
dirty russian misinformation
unverifiable
clinton dossier and yet no one has been
held accountable
nothing appears to have changed at all
john durham
anybody john durham where are you and
tonight it's not just the bureau's
fisa abuse that's concerning top
lawmakers
in the senate ron johnson he's now
demanding a meeting with director ray
after a classified security briefing
was partially leaked to the washington
post
in a deceptive way in order to make
republican lawmakers look like unwitting
russian stooges in other words they
haven't changed
apparently meanwhile over at the c.i.a
political correctness
far left canceled politics appears to be
a top concern
of america's spy agency take a look at
their
well let's call it cringeworthy new
recruiting video take a look
i'm a woman of color i am a mom i am a
cisgender millennial who's been
diagnosed with generalized anxiety
disorder
i am intersectional but my existence is
not a box checking exercise
i am a walking declaration a woman whose
inflection does not rise at the end of
her sentences
suggesting that a question has been
asked i did not sneak into cia
i am unapologetically me i want you
to be unapologetically you whoever you
are
know your worth command your space
mija you're worth it
cia's out there tonight defending the
video claiming that is
it is helping attract qualified
candidates but the ad is
getting mocked pretty much along both
political sides of the aisle
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else